whoa it's double pawns gifting 10 subs
so much hype 69 percent hype
oh but now 73 so much percent
things might be free and double upon
did leeches restart it didn't even
refresh but it looks like
i think it looks to be okay
cool we're gonna get another stafford
we might and boba bagan's gifting 10
subs
thanks so much yeah i really really
appreciate it
if takes knight here and then staffer oh
no stafford i can insist on the stafford
i'm playing a decently high rate of
player in a slower game
so there might be some incentive for my
opponent to take the pawn
yeah you can never have enough stafford
yeah if you were just gifted a sub by by
bobo
or by double the ponds or by night
befree say thank you
you have access to the emotes
okay we're going to have not a stafford
just kind of a italian
gioco piano
develop if d3 there's
um i can play knight a5 right away
but maybe not in this position
a6 is a very typical move give the
bishop some retreating square in the
vent of this
and now i'm not awake probably this move
oh you're not awake but you're resubbing
maybe you're resubbing in your
sleep it's a nice sleeping disorder
thank you was that satwik p
how did you get to this level of chess
you got to put in the time
i've been playing chess for about 20
years
um probably devoted well over
like 20 000 hours to the game
so it helps to like enjoy the process
too
i think passion is kind of the biggest
driver for improvement
okay i think i'll take and then go for
h6
emoji emoji
oh i have emojis now unexpected emojis
i'm beaming face with smiling eyes nice
okay let's play
i guess i can type notes here
huh fascinating
okay let's try and stay focused g5
g5 is actually typical if i'm not
committed to castling
the one issue might be after knight
takes
am i in trouble
probably not because i have rook g8 h4
c6 preventing knight d5
and queen f3 i've rooked g6 defending
the knight
um so white's probably likely to go back
and then i probably want to create some
like eventual attack against the king's
side
and maybe even castle queenside
oh okay so we're going into this i mean
i only
looked at this briefly
i thought it's okay
if it's not okay then i'll hopefully
learn something
remember i had a an over-the-board game
a few years ago
against ray robson and we have a very
similar situation
um in that game i missed a really cool
idea
but now i'm forgetting the idea it was
something like bishop g4
which maybe works here
like bishop g4 right away might be
playable
because if takes takes and uh the
bishop's defended by the rook
f pawns pins so there's no f3
one year hey happy anniversary
jean pannu and oh bo
bangs with 700 bits do you want to give
a new bin on stream lesson
oh i did that i actually did that a few
days ago i um
i do that once in a while um
i'm definitely open to the idea
sometimes what i'll do
was a few months ago i gave a lesson to
a friend and we just like pre-recorded
it
and then i put a good portion of it
on youtube but uh yeah very much open to
the idea
trying to do more um more noob friendly
content
and thanks yeah the subs keep coming in
oh bobo gifting five more subs thanks so
much
and follower subbing becoming a baby
okay i think i should play this move
just preventing knight
d5 and
then it's still kind of annoying this
pin
but uh yeah white wants to play f4
it's really reminding me of my my game
with ray
i'm fantasizing about like takes and
then here and mate but
ah can i make it work
it's kind of close to working like if
king d7 here
takes takes this would be pretty much
mating but then there would be f-takes
my initial idea was to put the queen on
e6
and just keep the knight defended get
out of the pin
um there's another idea here to play
to just sack the exchange and then play
knight h5
and attack the pawn
if g3 i take the pawn
that might be what i go for actually
because it's it's going to be hard for
white i'll have three
minor pieces attacking on the king side
f4 i take it
it just makes the position much easier
to play
i'm controlling all these squares so the
queen can't really like come
closer to the king side the square
a lot of squares in white territory
and in general when you have two minor
pieces for a rook in the middle game
that's even better than two minor pieces
for a rook in the end game
because the rooks don't really activate
until they have
files to work with and minor pieces are
usually better at attacking than rooks
okay so this move looks obvious
pinning the knight
i could have considered this but then i
would have had to calculate like queen
g3
i'm fantasizing getting my queen to h8
delivering double check and then mating
on h1
so it might require a bomb cloud
oh do i bond
i mean this is probably actually no it's
better to play king e7 keeping this pawn
defended
but let's not get too carried away
i could also just take the pawn oh no
then rook takes
that gets a bit confusing
i mean just king seven and good luck
with
takes
games tonight oh i appreciate that
yeah good night good luck good bishop
good king i'm born clouding for the win
i vaguely remember a gary
having it may have been a tournament
game where he had this move
like randomly in the middle game and i
was just winning because of this idea
um a g3 okay so my opponent's aware of
the danger
oh maybe i'm not winning so easily or
maybe i am
okay my time is dwindling so queen h8
if king if king g2 which i think was my
opponent's
intention i can take here and then
whatever takes back i
made on h3
does it just force mate
this is a made in one threat minor
pieces work really well together
oh it's not force mate oh the queen
defends
i was about to play a losing move there
oh but you know what i can do i i was
only thinking about the file but i'm
also
controlling the diagonal i can take
and then that was unintentional
a queen is actually kind of useful in
the corner
i saw one line but now i see two lines
now geometry is so important like
concept of board vision
okay so white's trying to create chaos
[Music]
um
i really want to play this move or this
move even
it seems like a position where i should
have at least a few winning ideas
maybe knight g3
like g3 is threatening maiden one it
controls h1
you might still might go for rook h1
but then i take and then rook takes and
then queen takes here
oh wait a minute if i take here there's
queen d4
check and then king f2
and then check and king e1
i'm not seeing the mate so maybe i
should just take and
keep things defended
i'd like to do something more forceful
f3 rook f3
oh this is probably the way to go
i spent a lot of time there i'm just
trying to keep things controlled okay
now
now i should calculate this i mean
there's still this move
but it's not as good because the king
doesn't have the escape route
so it's a force mate threat
i'm not seeing what white does
okay so white's going for this
um oh i can
take and after it takes i play f3
i'll always play f3
and the king's gonna be driven away from
the rook
whoa it's hey tj hey tj
thanks for gifting five subs
okay oh the king the king is in my crib
where's my win just push an f
on
someone was asking about f1 yesterday
and whether or not i watch it
i was watching it here anyway uh thanks
for the game
chess 960 lab
i've never really used this note feature
i guess you can take notes and then your
notes stay
even after the game it's good to know
um that was a fun game it was
yeah it was one of these like socks on
g5
where i think it was probably just good
for me
um but whenever you play g5 you you have
to anticipate this
and then decide whether it's uh worth
taking the risk
oh stockfish doesn't really like this
move
so bishop g3 is better but it's still
pleasant for black
it's kind of an interesting plan in
these italian positions where you
you delay castling you wait for white to
commit the bishop or commit the pawn or
both in this case
and then you get this quick attack with
um with the g-file push
so yeah i'm not sure if i missed
anything maybe cleaner
is king oh king e7 is the best move
let's go
it's actually it's pretty logical to get
the queen here
um
i feel validated by stockfish for my
bong clown
oh i missed a hello well i hope people
made up for it in chat
i'll try and catch up with chat the this
game kind of distracted me from chat
but sometimes it's vice versa where chat
will distract me from the game
um so e5
yeah okay there's a bunch of ways to win
oh someone was asking about bishop oh
bishop h3
i think i glazed over this move
but wouldn't have been sure about king
f3
oh wow yeah there's some fun lines here
it's fun when you have so many minor
pieces against kind of a
a naked king okay so that was the second
game of the stream um
if that goes on youtube i might
incorporate like some
some long cloud mention in the title
middle game bond cloud so if it goes on
youtube hi to youtube
subscribe follow on twitch very close to
300 000 subscribers on youtube
numbers just keep keep going up
yeah youtube is super deep with like
analytics
so we can see the list of countries here
kind of
so i'm sure iraq is probably like really
far
down oh yeah it only shows the top 50.
slovenia is number 50.
new zealand i would imagine
is in the top but maybe not
oh new zealand is yeah new zealand here
is here
so i guess it shows the number of views
i get from each country in the last 28
days
um but then what's interesting it shows
the average view duration
so the longer the view duration the
longer attention span
i guess people have in the given country
so oh so 11 minutes is the longest
oh sweden maybe is uh the longest
attention span 11 minutes and 14
seconds no norway
norway breaking 12 minutes
shout out to norway
yeah doesn't norway like have a tv
station where
they just watch like trains move
or they basically watch paint dry right
things in norway having a lucky number
of
views too i'm not sure if this accounts
for people who watch at like 2x speed
but maybe like some foreign countries
will watch slower
because it takes time to understand hey
it's grand master gary
gary i have a question for you also
thanks for reading shout out to gary
and use the gary command sub sup
oh sub or sup what's up
or what's up gary sobbing for 16 months
thanks so much i appreciate it
i was just showing the breakdown of like
who watches which countries watch
my youtube videos and it shows
it shows average view duration so norway
has the longest attention span at 12
minutes and three seconds per video
um which country has the shortest
attention span
india india watching less than
then seven minutes the philippines is
close
oh singapore singapore
falling even shorter
vietnam vietnam is only country
watching less than six minutes on
average
it might have something to do with the
language
or culture i don't know i want to go to
vietnam
someday
i have to do more india collabs because
india it's a huge
audience on youtube maybe like the
largest audience for
like the chess niche but these days i
mean there's so many countries watching
so gary my question for you i play the
game
not this game but uh i played a game
a few games ago this stream
and it was beautiful
but there was a moment in the game that
reminded me of you
where i played i played king seven
and i vaguely remember you posting
somewhere
that you it was like a puzzle
and this move i think it was you it was
your youtube video
wait let's find gory's youtube channel
fun fact about gary if you go to his
twitch channel
he has his youtube channel linked he's
also hosting me thanks corey
so let's go to gary's youtube
but what's the video called
oh you oh sorry gary's getting banned
and mocked by nightbot i'm just man gary
oh it's a mu it's the most beautiful
game he ever played
yeah it's it's kind of similar
it's like the same same sort of opening
at least
and the same kind of sack on g5
man this is the old version of chess.com
too
rewind oh and you also played rook g5
hey so many like parallel
similarities great minds think of like
in slightly different positions yeah
we're twinsies
so rook takes g5 pawndex g5
was also played by gary in this position
let's thumbs up
wait a minute you were black though
yeah you were bl it says you're black
here even though this implies that
you're white
and you played this against asserman
really so here i decided to be
aggressive
i just took the bishop
i knew that maybe i can transform
his attack and then convert into an
attack by me
it's like you know like judo or aikido
who's judo oh judo like martial arts
this is uh oh this was
inauguration day six years ago
except not quite but this was about six
years ago
whoa it's mark oh it's 93 gifting to
mark asterman
things might be free who is uh the
victim
of guard from the opponent's energy and
then reword it back to him so
uh the fact that he sacrificed analogy
files against me i'm strong square
um hey it's lula how's it going
it's really uh attacking the king here
and also
the queen is coming in mm-hmm so again
i'm using his energy against him
so he played queen d2 yeah i hope you
don't mind that
now we're watching the story it's very
shocking
so try to take a few seconds or as much
time pause the video and see what mode
that black can play here that was
that will basically be a complete
devastation for white
okay so we're pausing we're following
instructions also might be free
thanks for gifting a sub to lily yeah
i'm on a weird sleep schedule
so i'm more on
not quite european time maybe australian
time
but thanks so much might be free and
lila i hope you're doing well
uh shout out to everyone watching if
you're just joining
uh we're watching gary's brilliant video
it's blocked to move in this position
so our i guess our positions weren't
super
[Music]
they're yeah they were a bit different
in my king e7 it was less um
maybe a bit less forcing i don't know
it's a mood that is very unorthodox it's
it's rarely seen it's incredibly
pleasing did the bomb cloud exist
in 2015
that was before hikaru like started his
bomb cloud speed runs um but
it's totally crushing it activates two
of black's pieces
and two starts the mating attack that is
oh it activates the king
too find it i hope you found it so
basically i gotta get
this queen in the attack but
unfortunately this pawn is protected
and in the way so i want to get the
queen here
so how do i do that the answer struck me
right i know i lost against
him but i just got a nasty rook fork
smiley face
forget about castling forget about wait
was that
well being at the room i was arguing
that's the way i just
wanted to mate him right away yeah king
k7 is so beautiful
because white can't really stop queenie
chase uh we're not gonna watch the whole
thing but i'll leave the link
people should check out and subscribe to
gary's channel
yeah he was i think he started his
channel before i started my channel like
this is like og yeah version one of
chess.com
and you can see so if you look really
closely
he did a video gary versus hikaru
he beat hacaro in 18 moves i think
um anyway okay that's the plug for gary
thanks for the thanks for the nostalgia
it's very rare that you see this move
actually working